we really need a president who is not the
laughing stock of the world and once again,
leaders have been caught on video laughing
at Donald Trump this time.
It's Russian president Vladimir Putin and
Syrian dictator Bashar Al Assad.
Remember that it was Donald Trump who said,
we need a non laughingstock president.
He tweeted back in 2014 when Barack Obama
was president.
We need a president who isn't the laughing
stock to the entire world.
We need a truly great leader, a genius at
strategy and winning respect.
He claimed he would be that president.
Here's video of Putin and Assad laughing at
Trump.
Now, of course, they're not speaking in English.
It's Russian with Putin using the aid of a
translator.
So I'll summarize what was said per Axios.
The video shows the leaders talking to each
other while visiting the Orthodox church of
the Virgin Mary in Damascus.
Assad tells Putin about the apostle Paul,
who became Christian at the gate of Damascus
and he jokingly says, if Trump arrives along
this road, everything will be normal with
him to Putin.
Then laughs and tells a sod, it will be repaired.
Invite him.
He will come and Assad answers.
He's ready to invite Trump to which Putin
responds, smiling.
I will tell him, and they all laugh and what
you have to understand is the literal translation
doesn't really do it justice.
Let's look at the video where they are just
laughing and having a grand old time laughing
at Trump.
Then I'll explain the sort of gist of this
[inaudible]
this is happening all the time.
World leaders laughing at Trump, so the literal
translation doesn't make the joke totally
obvious, but it would sort of be like saying,
you know, you should invite Trump to visit
the road to Damascus.
If walking that road led Paul to see the light,
maybe it would fix Donald Trump as well.
The idea being that Trump is clueless.
That's the gist of it.
Remember that a few months ago, Donald Trump
left the NATO summit early after world leaders,
including the Canadian prime minister, Justin
Trudeau, French president Emmanuel McCrone
and British prime minister Boris Johnson were
caught on video laughing at Trump.
Here's that video.
As
a reminder, Trump so triggered by that one
that he left the NATO summit early, and then
of course there was the time that the entire
room full of the United nations national assembly
laughed at Donald Trump's ridiculous hyperbole
in 2018 a particularly orange looking Trump
getting a laugh, but he wasn't telling any
jokes.
Today I stand before the United nations general
assembly to share the extraordinary progress
we've made in less than two years.
My administration has accomplished more than
almost any administration in the history of
our country.
America is so true.
Didn't expect that reaction, but that's
okay.
Weren't
we supposed to be getting away from the laughing
stock president by electing Donald Trump?
It's the opposite.
It's the same projection.
It's all the stuff Trump said Obama was doing
or represented or was.
Trump actually is all the things that Trump
said Hillary would do if she were to become
president.
Trump is actually doing wild, trying to take
credit for things that he actually had nothing
to do with.
I'm sick of having a laughingstock president.
I want to fix this.
Let's fix it.
In November,